[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 28 mars bienvenue
dans le statut de journal préparé par la
rédaction de tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de cette édition le lancement de
l'association élu local yvelines ce
matin à saint germain en laye porté par
la sénatrice martha de sidra qu'elle
fait la promotion des femmes en
politique sur le territoire le
département mauvaise élève en la matière
avec moins de 20% de femmes maires de
communes
le site est à but que le centre
d'éducation et d'élevage jacques bougnol
forme une quinzaine de chiens guides
pour les personnes aveugles ou
malvoyantes une formation qui coûte 25
mille euros par animal ce matin le
préfet des yvelines jean jacques brot
s'est rendu sur place et nous allons
vous donner l'envié de vous divertir à
la fin de ce journal avec le bac bleu
backboard un jeu 100% yvelinois imaginé
et conçu par un habitant de saint rémy
les chevreuse françois guérin c'est le
portrait de la rédaction sur ce plateau
tout à l'heure des invités aussi nous
parlerons de la collecte lancée par une
association de la verrière pour le
mozambique le pays d'afrique ravagé par
le cyclone ida y est nous évoquerons
également les 50 ans de l'association
entraide scolaire amicale anniversaire
au niveau national mais aussi au niveau
local puisque l'antenne de guyancourt
fête ses 10 ans mais avant cette
information une partie du mur d'enceinte
de la maison centrale de poissy s'est
effondré aujourd'hui les faits se sont
produits alors que des travaux de
réhabilitation étaient effectués sur ce
mur effondrement de plus de 30 mètres de
long du côté de l'avenue des ursulines
l'axé fermée à la circulation jusqu'à
nouvel ordre un périmètre de sécurité a
été mis en place la mairie de poissy
recommande d'éviter le secteur aucun
détenu n'a pris la fuite et aucun blessé
n'est à déplorer pour le moment la
parité cause difficile à obtenir est ce
le cas aussi en politique le département
des yvelines est celui qui compte le
moins de femmes mères en ile-de-france
la sénatrice martha de sidrac et
d'autres élus se mobilisent donc pour
une plus grande présence et
reconnaissance des femmes politiques
elles ont lancé ce matin l'association
héliciel les détails de manon varaldo
les yvelines sont le département qui
compte le moins de femmes mères dans la
région sonia breux au maire de saint cyr
l'école et à néry le pallec maire de
cheuvreux sondés
exception elles font partie de
l'association elie lancé ce matin dans
le but de promouvoir les femmes dans les
yvelines qui désirent s'investir pour le
territoire nous vraiment ce qu'on
voudrait faire partager c'est notre
expérience de femme et lui faire
profiter des femmes qui souhaiteraient
s'engager qui ont des hésitations des
questions des interrogations leur
montrer que c'est possible je reste
persuadé que le femmes et un homme sont
complémentaires
là où je me pose question c'est sur une
le fait de devoir le l'imposer pour que
ça devienne effectif
face à ce manque de femmes dans les
effectifs des exécutifs locaux comme à
l'échelle nationale la sénatrice martin
de sidra qu'a lancé elie l'association
de promotion des femmes en politique
dans les yvelines
c'est tout simplement de permettre aux
femmes dose est d'aller plus loin dans
leurs ambitions parce que les femmes ont
également des ambitions et l'y
accompagnera également les élus dans
leur mandat et proposera à ses adhérents
des rencontres et des formations autour
des mandats politiques
on est toujours aux liens parce que
l'idée c'est de créer du réseau l'idée
c'est de créer du lien
cette association est également ouverte
aux hommes interpelle la secrétaire de
la délégation aux droits des femmes et à
l'égalité des chances entre les hommes
et les femmes
messieurs nous sommes à vos côtés et
nous avons longtemps de légitimité que
vous a aussi un moment donné nous saisir
de cet espace public
la cotisation à l'association elie et
d'un montant de 25 euros
c'est un projet entrer dans le concret
il ya quelques mois après 20 ans de
discussions mais peut-être déjà mise à
mal l'enfouissement de la nationale 10 à
trappes sera-t-il repoussé suite au
chantier préparatoire des travaux de
couverture d'une première portion au
niveau de la mairie devait démarrer en
septembre
problème 14 millions d'euros promis par
l'état à cette année ne sont pas sûrs
d'arriver le sujet a été évoqué en
comité de pilotage l'état explique faire
face à des rentrées financières en
baisse due à la dégradation et des
radars depuis le début du mouvement des
gilet jaune plus de 60% des appareils
auraient été mises hors service
et des arbitrages seront rendus
prochainement sur ce dossier de la
nationale 10 il ya quinze jours le
sud-est de le sud est de l'afrique a été
touchée par le cyclone ida y pays
durement frappé par la catastrophe le
mozambique où le cyclone a fait plus de
500 morts et où une centaine de milliers
de personnes sont aujourd'hui sans abri
pour en parler sandra de pina bonsoir
lance alors vous êtes élu dans la ville
de la verrière et vous est également la
présidente de l'association vers
hyéroise enfants du petit pays et vous
avez lancé une collecte de une collecte
pour le mozambique pour venir en aide
aux sinistrés au mozambique pourquoi
lancer cette initiative ou pour
différentes raisons
ce qui lie aujourd'hui mon association
mozambique premièrement c'est que je
suis portugais d'origine capverdienne
donc à ce lien d'un point de vue
financier c'est le pollen de portugaise
exactement et puis à l'eau fait aussi
que j'ai des membres de la famille qui
sont mozambicains et puis j'ai à g un
bénévole qui est de bérat originaire de
bera bera qui est l'une des villes
principales a indiqué qu est la ville la
plus touchée par les cas d'actes mans la
deuxième ville du mozambique en termes
de superficie habitations donc ça nous
ça nous a touchés voilà on avait
vraiment envie de faire quelque chose on
a vu qu'ils avaient pas des collectes
qui sont lancés entre temps mais où
c'est plus des demandes d'argent
d'accord nous on est dans les deux donc
on a créé un coin litchi en ligne mais
on a
né aussi beaucoup dans le plus dans les
produits les produits que le numéraire
telle est la situation sur place
aujourd'hui on ne sait plus de 500 morts
des centaines de milliers de sans abri
c'est une véritable catastrophe sur
place c'est l'une des plus grosses
catastrophes signer la scène la plus
grosse catastrophe que le sud africain a
connu il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
l'eau n'est toujours pas descendu donc
c'est toujours très compliqué de pouvoir
secourir les personnes qui attendent
toujours ceux qui ont survécu sont
parfois encore sur les toits en attente
et ça fait quand même deux semaines
voilà donc la situation n'est pas du
tout évidente et le mozambique n'arrive
pas à faire face aujourd'hui donc dû la
raison plus il peut y avoir
d'intervenants mais ça sera pour le
mozambique ou que vous l'avez dit le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que ces zones
ne redescende pas un souci qui se pose
après le passage du cyclone c'est la
présence d'eau stagnante et aussi le
manque d'accès à l'eau potable et qui
sont propices ses conditions à la
propagation du choléra c'est si
l'inquiétude sur place c'est une
inquiétude pour l'instant il essaye de
dire aux personnes ne pas trop boire
cette eau jusqu à maintenant il ya eu
que cinq cas est ce que ces cinq cas qui
ont été décrétés ou est-ce qu'il y en a
d'autres et on ne le sait pas mais
aujourd'hui au moment où je vous parle
il y en a que 5
c'est plutôt rassurant mais ce qui est
peut-être inquiétant c'est que si la
situation continue comme ça les cinq cas
vont se multiplier
et là ça sera pas la même chose du coup
quelles sont les urgences aujourd'hui
sur place envoyer des fonds envoyés des
produits de première nécessité des
produits de première nécessité après les
font bien sûr qu'ils en font
puisqu'aujourd'hui pour berra s'est dans
un premier temps effectivement essayer
de nourrir les personnes se couvrir les
blessés autres mais après il ya toute la
phase de reconstruction et elle est
beaucoup plus longue celle là tel
produit peut-on donner à votre
association
nous on entend demander tout ce qui est
vêtements chaussures hommes femmes
enfants bébés donc et puis tous les
aliments secs ça va être comme des pâtes
du riz des haricots secs et autres ça va
être des produits d'hygiène mais ça va
être aussi tout ce qui est linge de
maison vaisselle en fait à partir du
moment où c'est en bonne étoile et
propre sur tout ce qu'on demande aux
gens c'est de nous ramener des choses
propres puisque en fait on n'a pas le
temps vraiment de les laver aujourd'hui
s'est emballé et envoyez donc mais cette
collecte vous l'avez dit vous l'avez
lancé quasiment les jours qui ont suivi
cette catastrophe ce que vous avez eu
pour le moment beaucoup de produits vous
êtes en attente encore de beaucoup de
produits
les personnes ont répondu présentes
encore celles qui ont eu l'info je pense
que plus il y aura d'un quart à
l'information plus ils répondront c'est
pas la première fois qu'on fait des
collectes pour soutenir éventuellement
une cause donc on a toujours eu des
personnes qui sont venus nous soutenir
on a déjà pas mal de choses mais ça
remplit pas encore un contenaire faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui l'ambassade à
paris a mis à disposition un contenaire
afin qu'on puisse t'envoyer tout ce
qu'on va collecter on n'y est pas donc
voilà on aimerait bien que ce soit un
voire même plus de plus que 1 des
contenaires mais ça serait bien que on
puisse avoir ce qu'il faut et pour avoir
ce qu'ils font il faut que les gens
aient l'info et jean phi semaine hier
j'ai vu poser la question pour acheminer
les produits sur place et l'ambassade du
mozambique en france c'est ça qui a mis
à disposition exactement qui met en
place donc ce ce conteneur comment on
donne ses produits comme on prend
contact avec vous alors il ya le lien de
votre page facebook qui a pu s'afficher
et pendant cet entretien
comment on donne ses produits comment
peut-on donner écoutez il faut les
déposer au local que nos amis la
disposition la commune puisque ça fait
six ans en fait que qu'on a ce petit
local est donc aujourd'hui c'est au 11
avenue du général leclerc sur la
verrière bien faut simplement appeler un
des numéros soit le mien soit celui du
bénévole en question à tito et y avoir
des infos concernant éventuellement les
heures complètes là on a des heures
d'ouverture vraiment très précise mais
s'il ya vraiment des plus grandes
quantités on peut venir ouvrir
exceptionnellement afin de récupérer les
noms un dernier mot sur votre
association outre cette collecte quel
type d'action vous menez sur le
territoire on en a quelques-uns
éventuellement la semaine internationale
des droits de l'enfant
tous les ans du 14 au 20 novembre ça
fait cinq ans que nous sommes là ça fait
cinq ans qu'on la fait du mal à
commencer à la deuxième année puisque la
première année on ne l'a pas fait sur
sur la verrière on avait fait à
fontenay-sous-bois et donc depuis cinq
ans le fait sur la verrière et donc
voilà c'est vraiment dj aux droits des
enfants c'est vraiment à des soirées à
thème d après midi en formation des
échanges avec les parents et
éventuellement tout ce qui est
intervention de la part de l'aministie
internationale qui nous qui nous
soutient et qui nous suit aussi depuis
le début il cette action du moment cette
collecte donc pour les sinistrés du
mozambique toutes les informations à
retrouver bien sûr sur la page facebook
que de d'enfants d'enfants du petit pays
merci sandra dos pinhais d'être passé
sur ce plateau présidente de cette
association une carte scolaire du taux
de pollution en ile de france elle a été
publiée aujourd'hui par l'association
respire constat sans appel 6 182 des
12500 établissements scolaires
franciliens ont un air extérieur au
dessus des normes de la pollution au
dioxyde d'azoté les écoles les plus
touchées sont bien sûr dans l'hyper
centre de paris et la petite couronne à
l'instar et des autres départements de
grande couronne les écoles des yvelines
s'en sortent mieux
respire préconise est de mettre en place
des zones à faibles émissions autour des
établissements
le préfet des yvelines jean jacques brot
était ce jeudi matin en déplacement au
centre d'élevage et d'éducation et
jacques bougnol abus
un lieu qui forme et qui est due que
chaque année plusieurs dizaines de
chiens guides pour aveugles et
malvoyants avec l'aide notamment à des
dons du grand public le reportage de
michael et demi d'euros les chiens
guides d'aveuglés l'honneur ce jeudi 28
mars le préfet des yvelines est venu
visiter pendant deux heures le centre
d'élevage et d'éducation jacques bougnol
installé depuis septembre 2015 à buc
au programme découverte des boxes de
maternité pour les shows et
démonstrations avec les éducateurs
spécialisés
c'est important de montrer une activité
assez méconnu qui est essentiel pour le
bien-être d'un certain nombre de
malvoyants et aveugles et que qui est
une fonction sociale humaine extrêmement
intéressante positive au total une
quinzaine de chiens sont formées en même
temps sur ce site de 2000 mètres carrés
y sont pris en main par 18 éducateurs
des trois mois et demi pour les rendre
opérationnelles après au minimum 18 mois
de formation
ce sont des chiens qui vont avoir une
relation extraordinaire avec leurs
maîtres en eux en eux mêmes
est-ce qu'ils sont extraordinaires en
tout cas ils font tout ce qu'il faut
pour pour assumer la leur mission mais
ça c'est notre responsabilité de choisir
des chiens particulièrement équilibré
est particulièrement réactif à ce qu'on
leur demande
coût total pour la formation d'un chien
près de 25000 euros pour les aider les
lieutenants de louveterie désigneront
remis un chèque de 500 euros lors de
cette journée
samedi une marche mondiale est organisée
pour sensibiliser à l'endométriose cette
maladie gynécologique touche une femme
sur dix en france y est souvent banalisé
et demain vendredi manon varaldo parlera
de ce sujet dans l'émission 7 8 l'hebdo
un reportage notamment à la rencontre
des femmes atteintes de la pathologie
extraits de leurs témoignages
j'avais vraiment des douleurs qui était
assez permanente et on me donnait du
coup du mur fait non on me disait que
c'était normal que voilà c'était des
règles et je commençais à voir vraiment
des des douleurs comme si en fait on
vous donne des coups de poignard dans le
dos le ventre en fait je ne pouvais pas
me lever de mon lit par moments j'étais
plié fallait que je me mette en mode
foetus il n'y a que comme ça que
j'arrivais à essayer on va dire
d'atténuer la douleur
les médicaments ne fonctionnait plus
j'avais
extrêmement mal et peur aussi dorée
avoir un prochain cycle parce que les
douleurs étaient vraiment très très
intenses
on peut plus marcher on va s'évanouir à
des bouffées de chaleur
zombies quoi bon billet qui souffrent
reportage complet à retrouver demain
dans l'émission 7 8 l'hebdo invités de
cette émission le professeur arnaud
fauconnier impliqués dans la recherche
sur l'endométriose économie à présent
avec le choeur de saint quentin en
yvelines qui poursuit son évolution
plusieurs opérations de démolition et de
reconstruction se déroule afin de
répondre aux besoins et des entreprises
et des salariés exemple ce jeudi avec le
complexe proxima 5 qui a été inaugurée
wilfried richy et aurélie ans avec ses
6700 mètres carrés ces 500 postes de
travail et ses 170 places de parking
proxima 5 est la dernière réalisation en
date pour cfc développement un promoteur
immobilier actif depuis la fin des
années 70 sur l'agglomération
quand on est 1 300 mm car est construit
sur 51 10
peut-être plus d'ailleurs j'ai jamais
fait les comptes on a détruit un
immeuble qui était qui avait été
construit il y à 35 ans environ qui
faisait environ 4500 m² et qui faisait
rez-de-chaussée plus de niveaux sur la
partie conservée en sous-sol sur les
fondations existantes vont construire un
immeuble plus haut en r + 5 plus lourd
20 % plus lourd
voilà le déjà là le paramètres
techniques spécifiques liés à cet
ensemble
la direction régionale d'aînés disent ça
viendra prendre possession des locaux
dans les prochains mois eun et 10
arrivée en 2011 à saint quentin en
yvelines et qui s'était alors installé à
montigny le bretonneux ce qui nous
attire à 50 ans et le développement
économique la présence de nombreuses
entreprises la présence des transports
50 ans est une terre d'innovation dans
lequel nous on peut nouer de multiples
partenariats avec ben les autres
entreprises du territoire des start-up
l'agglomération saint quentin en
yvelines dispose de 5 millions de m²
d'immobilier d'entreprise avec encore
deux cent cinquante mille mètres carrés
en développement rajustement des
opérations comme celle du proxima 5 sur
laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui nous
pouvons garder les entreprises sur le
territoire qu'ils sont
installés dans deux les mieux de en de
l'immobilier obsolète et qui grâce à ces
nouvelles opérations justement peuvent
déménager mais en même temps se
regrouper on est sur une dynamique que
ce soit sur le padula que ce soit sur le
centre de saint quentin donc guyancourt
montini on a vraiment une belle
dynamique de projets immobiliers deux
anniversaires en un seul événement ce2
les halles entraide scolaire amical ce
samedi à la maison de quartier pierre
mendès france l'association fêtera son
50e anniversaire au niveau national mais
également les dix ans de son antenne à
guyancourt et j'en parle tout de suite
avec mes deux invités geneviève sagbohan
et christian proulx bonsoir à vous deux
co responsable de cette antenne de lézat
à guyancourt alors l'association propose
un accompagnement aux enfants et
adolescents que leurs parents ne peuvent
ni aidé ou ne peuvent pas faire aider
christian proulx vous est également
membre du conseil d'administration de
lézat au niveau national comment
s'effectuent cet accompagnement alors
d'abord faut savoir qu'il ya 3500
bénévoles partis dans différentes
antennes dans toute la france qui
suivent 4100 enfants du cp jusqu'au
jusque scotia réuni dernièrement donc
comment ça se passe d'abord c'est
trouver les familles donc ça en
travaillant en étroite collaboration
avec les établissements scolaires soient
les enseignants ou assistante sociale
qui détecte les enfants ont dit aux
réelles difficultés et qui dont les
parents certains n'ont pas été à l'école
ou très peu à l'école donc ils peuvent
pas les aider
ou alors ils n'ont pas les moyens pour
des cours particuliers
quand on sait combien ça coûte donc bien
déjà une indication qui est fait par les
enseignantes qui les renseignent et
parents pour que éventuellement ils nous
appellent
or s'ils sont volontaires ça c'est
disons la proche des enfants des
familles alors l'accompagnement c'est
pas de l'aide aux devoirs
c'est plus que ça le pic tiff c'est
qu'ils soient autonomes ou long terme
qui puisse travailler même donc fait
quand même où les aides
voir il ya l'aide aux devoirs mais c'est
pas que ça non c'est pas que ça parce
que c'est qu'une heure par semaine il
faut savoir notre slogan c'est un enfant
un bénévole une heure par semaine
minimum et au domicile de l'enfant
alors pourquoi au domicile de l'enfant
c'est ce que c'est important qu'on ait
le contact avec les parents on exige
qu'ils aient au moins un des deux
parents qu'ils soient présents quand on
vient pour ne serait ce que pour montrer
ce qu'on fait parce que c'est une de nos
missions c'est d'aider les parents à
comprendre les enjeux de scolaires on
les emmène voir les enseignants pour des
rendez vous avec les enseignants parce
qu'ils n'osent pas toujours aller voir
l'enseignant donc ça c'est important
parce qu'on sait la réussite des enfants
sa part ses primes en l2 les deux les
émissions mondiales pour le futur le
juge des enfants
tout à fait puis ça passe par une
collaboration étroite du bénévole avec
l'enseignant et avec les paroles parce
que l'on remplace pas les parents donc
et si on veut que je sois cet
accompagnement passe par la réussite
il vaut mieux que ce soit au bout de
deux ou trois ans que l'enfant puisse
être autonome et puis je continuer à
profiter de la scolarité que vous en
parliez c'est une association qui a
implanté dans toute la france alors oui
c'est une association qui est donc été
créée en 1969 à paris qui a essaimé dans
tous les arrondissements de paris puis
ensuite dans l'île de france et
maintenant en province actuellement donc
les enfants se seraient partis à peu
près moitié moitié en province des
matières en ile de france est apparu a
été reconnue d'utilité publique reconnue
dit et public
ce qui est surtout important c'est qu'on
soit reconnu par l'éducation nationale
en tant qu'association éducatifs
complémentaires de l'enseignement public
ça permet de mettre des projets avec les
établissements scolaires on aura
l'occasion d'en parler sur les yvelines
est ce que c'est bien implanté ce
qu'elle est forte et solide il ya 150
enfants qui sont suivis dans cette ville
mieux encore il ya aussi rambouillet il
ya aussi conflans sainte honorine le
chesnais trap est aussi carrière sur
scène et donc ça fait sept communes qui
sont donc les as est implanté qui est
des enfants et cette antenne aussi à
guyancourt je me tourne vers vous
geneviève sagbo en disant qu'elle existe
c'est un ami
versez important on peut le dire pour
l'enterrer donc oui bien sûr disant oui
c'est surtout que au début n'y avait que
quelques bénévoles maintenant nous
sommes cette année nous nous sommes
quarante bénévoles et nous suivons 46
enfants la place du bénévole on l'a
compris est importante pour pour cet
accompagnement mais c'est toujours
bénévole on peut rien faire il ya des
besoins en bénévoles pas spécialement en
ce moment il n'y a aucun enfant fin tous
les éléments trop excusez moi tous les
enfants ont bien un bénévole mais on va
commencer à préparer la rentrée
prochaine donc c'est des personnes
veulent nous rejoindre
pas de problème mais depuis dix ans
combien d'enfants ont pu être
accompagnés par les arts n'a pas fait le
calcul mais ce grand-père femme à la
soixantaine
ça fait de son enfant d'accord est en ce
moment en ce moment 46 enfants
quarante six enfants dont les deux tiers
sont plutôt en primaire et un tiers en
collèges et de lycées et comment
justement fonctionne cette antenne de
guyancourt
alors cette antenne en fait elle
fonctionne ça nous sommes en relation
très étroite avec neuf écoles primaires
et puis les collèges de guyancourt donc
ce sont les enseignants les équipes
éducatives qui nous signale des enfants
en difficulté et ensuite nom christian
et moi nous avons rencontré la famille
l'enfant et on revient après avec un
bénévole on leur présente un bénévole et
ce bénévole après accompagnent l'enfant
pendant au moins une année scolaire
on l'a compris ce lien avec les écoles
du territoire ça c'est aussi très
important de ce travail de collaboration
franche et même le bénévole après
continue est en contact avec
l'enseignant si on veut que l'aide soit
efficace
il faut que les bénévoles puissent
comprendre exactement quels sont les
points faibles de l'enfant et en plus le
bénévole permet aussi de renforcer les
liens entre les parents et les
enseignants
dernière question saint quentin au
niveau national 10 ans pour cette
antenne de guyancourt qu'est ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter pour cet
anniversaire pour ses anniversaires
ben déjà l'anniversaire se présente bien
puisqu'on fait donc une petite fête vous
en aviez parlé mois déjà au moins 120
personnes qui y vont venir
madame le maire de riom co a dit qu'elle
viendrait aussi la présidente de
l'association va venir aussi au niveau
national au niveau national et revers
aussi une principale du collège des
soldats qui ont travaillé très
étroitement où il ya justement une est
passé nos segments général professionnel
adapté avec qui on a des bons rapports
donc ça va nous permettre peut-être de
continuer à se développer sur lui ont
couru puis grâce à vous sur les yvelines
le lien ou souhaitant un bon
anniversaire merci à vous deux jeunes de
l'as haguenau christian crude est
repassé sur ce plateau pour les 50 ans
de l'êta au niveau national et les dix
ans de cette antenne à guyancourt pour
enfermer pour refermer ce journal
partons à la rencontre est présent de
françois guérin c'est un habitant de
saint rémy les chevreuse après avoir
sillonné le monde comme commercial cet
habitant a décidé de mettre à profit ses
connaissances du monde de l'entreprise
il a créé et conçu la craie et il a
élaboré un jeu pour sa ville c'est le
portrait de la rédaction signé marylène
iapichino qui dedecker distribution de
petits coussinets appelé pas à l'espace
jeunes de saint rémy les chevreuse ce
jour là les enfants vont découvrir le
pad board
c'est le premier cap 21 qui a gagné mais
il ne faut pas qu'ils dépassent d'un
terrain autrement il redescend à 15 3
points pour un bac dans la cible un
point s'il reste sur la planche en
équipe des variantes sont possibles
sportif les jeunes de saint rémy les
chevreuse contre les objectifs 50.40
oui je crois c'est super il faut courir
mais c'est moi je ne viens pas de bien
loin françois guérin l'imaginer le
peaufine chez lui à saint rémy les
chevreuse
tout a commencé avec un prototype qu'il
a lui même fabriqué mais le premier
était avec la même idée mais avec une
une caisse derrière qui permettait de
mettre les bags pour les transporter
c'est quand même très compliqué c'est
lourd c'est pas facile à fabriquer mais
bon l'idée était là un an de réflexion
pour élaborer l'objet final qui a déjà
fait des petits backboard family
backboard adapte backboard happiness
family pour les le grand public adapte
pour les ehpad et les handicaps et happy
days pour les entreprises sont nos
marchés principaux pour le moment le
tout est stocké est conditionné au fond
de sa cour bienvenue dans dans la bacb
ordre house la g400 backboard qui
viennent d'arriver et donc l'idée c'est
que
maintenant il faut les conditionner les
emballer et c'est moi qui m'occupe à ce
que je vérifie chaque planche une par
une et chaque coussinets aussi un par un
pour avoir une qualité maximale une
qualité 100% saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse
françois guérin s'entoure des artisans
de la commune pour parfaire son jeu
le menuisier conçoit les planches et les
retouches depuis le début du projet il
en est de même pour la couturière
le deuxième objectif c'est des nouveaux
sacs quand il a une nouvelle idée et il
vient me voir on réfléchit ensemble et
je dis que des noms ça ça va pas ça
c'est pas comme ça où
et au niveau couture je suis
intransigeante sur sur les aspects que
je vois il faut que ce soit parfait avec
trois backboard à son actif françois
guérin ne compte pas en rester là
son but développer cette entreprise pour
ensuite la cedh est un jeune ou une
personne en recherche d'emploi à la voix
de ce reportage marylène iapichino que
vous retrouvez dans un instant pour
l'émission 7,8 loisirs c'est la fin de
ce journal belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]